[Music]
welcome back everybody we're headed
right now to Lancaster County
Pennsylvania where a U.S posters postal
service worker sued over religious
discrimination and the United States
Supreme Court is now taking up the case
Gerald Groff delivered mail for seven
years with USPS except on Sundays you
see Groff is an Evangelical Christian
and believes that the Sabbath should be
dedicated entirely to rest and worship
there's a clause in the Civil Rights Act
of 1964 making it unlawful to
discriminate and against anyone's
compensation terms conditions or
privileges of employment because of
religion unless it causes undue hardship
for the business when the post office
contracted with Amazon to deliver
packages on Sundays Groff's employers
originally accommodated him still
allowing him the day off but that only
lasted a year the boss said that things
changed at the office and he'd either
have to work on Sundays or quit now
after running into this problem several
other USPS location efficiency
eventually resigned and sued the company
for religious discrimination according
to court filings USPS disagrees on the
basis that it is not legally required to
accommodate Groff because of the
hardship the Supreme Court is scheduled
to hear arguments on this issue next
week and will submit a decision before
the end of June so let's talk about it
Brian the USPS originally or was
supposedly worked with Graf for a year
trying to accommodate him just didn't
really work out does that fact help the
USPS to show that they tried to help it
in the first place yeah Jesse so
reasonable accommodation is a part of
the analysis of the Supreme Court has
already put forward in previous cases
and will probably revisit to look at
this case at least here the United
States Postal Service has for a lack of
a better term the receipts to say look
at what we try to do look at how much it
cost us and this is why we couldn't make
an accommodation this is a very rural
area from my understanding it's a very
few people work at the post office it's
not a large Metropolitan City where you
can just find someone to replace him and
it'll be a lot easier I think they may
have a strong argument based on the
receipts they present to the court as to
how they tried to accommodate him but
failed well let's reverse it Terry do
you think that there is a strong
possibility that Graf may win the case
against his employer and if so can you
explain why he would have a strong
argument I definitely think he has a
stronger argument and Brian I'll take
you up on that bet and here's why the
post office actually did accommodate him
for quite some time and it wasn't an
undue hardship and that's the phrase
right there undo hardship and it used to
be that for religion that undue hardship
was just something that was a more than
de minimis so but now after Ada that
undue hardship has been defined at least
when there's a disability to be
something very substantial you have to
really show that your business is going
to go out of business and I think the
Supreme Court is ready to look at this
even Gorsuch has said in cases where
they declined to review that it's time
to look at those original cases that
looked at religion well I think that
this is a fascinating case if only there
were cameras in the Supreme Court but
that's I guess is an issue for another
episode of Law and crime daily when we
come back a mother in Arizona thought
that her daughter was kidnapped after
she got a phone call asking for ransom
money up next we'll look at the latest
scam backed by artificial intelligence
foreign
[Music]
telligence is becoming more common in
everyday life with the goal of course of
making everything easier but that comes
at a price at least according to one
mother in Arizona she says that AI put
her through the scariest hoax of her
life Jennifer D Stefano received a call
from an unfamiliar number and almost let
it go to voicemail but you remembered
that her teenage daughter was on a
skiing trip and wanted to make sure that
she was okay the woman thought she heard
her daughter's voice saying mom I messed
up while sobbing a man's voice is heard
soon after telling the teen to put her
head back and lie down that same man
told DiStefano that he had her daughter
and threatened to drug her if police
were contacted now at first he demanded
one million dollars in Ransom but when
DeStefano said that she didn't have the
money the caller said he'd take fifty
thousand dollars instead D Stefano
eventually called 9-1-1 and got a hold
of her daughter who was still on the
skiing trip who had no kidnapper in
sight police believe that the scammer
was able to spoof her daughter's Voice
using artificial intelligence now while
the identity of di Stefano's scammer is
unknown law enforcement suggests keeping
social media profiles and other pages
that are linked to your voice private if
you do get a call like this one ask the
caller plenty of questions and be on the
lookout for any inconsistencies but
let's talk about this so Brian what kind
of charges could a person face like this
if they ran this type of scam so Jesse
larceny isn't just what we're thinking
of normally taking someone's money out
of their pocket or or taking something
off of their property there's a thing
called larceny by Trick or larceny by
deception and that's based on these
types of scams that people run if for
example this happened in New York trying
to steal a million dollars even through
a trick or deception like this that's a
big felony you can get what eight in the
third to 25 years and even negotiating
that fifty thousand dollars you're still
looking at what seven years as a D
Felony it's a lot it makes me a little
worried like should we start speaking in
accents can they take our voices just on
the show I don't know ask a lot of
questions like you said I think we need
to put a filter on The Daily I've
somehow filter our voices so they can't
be captured I mean Terry we were showing
pictures of the money right there let's
talk the Civil front I imagine you could
file a lawsuit for extreme emotional
distress for what this mother went
through well you know no question you
can it actually is one of my favorite
charges intentional infliction of
emotional distress and in Arizona there
is a cause of action for that it's a
two-year statute of limitations so
they'd have to bring that within that
two-year period but you have to show
that there was some outrageous behavior
that that behavior caused the emotional
distress and it has to be severe and it
has to be extreme I do think here this
is the most extreme distress you could
possibly have a parent thinking that
their child might have been kidnapped
and thinking that they would have to pay
a million dollars to get the child
returned or even fifty thousand dollars
so I think if they were to bring that
type of action they could Prevail and I
do think that they should consider that
they of course probably wouldn't be able
to recover they don't even have the
suspect yet but it's certainly something
that you can do in Arizona and it is
probably the most extreme distress that
anyone could have I think it's
fascinating the Law changes right we
finally get videotapes we get
surveillance footage we get phone calls
to tie in defendants and now we don't
even know if it's reliable there could
be deep fakes all over the place Brian
Terry thank you so much everyone out
there thanks for joining us here on Long
crime daily we're going to see you next
time as we discuss Justice in America
thank you
[Music]